to understand the solution, it's useful to draw the exponential function.
e⁰ is 1 and then it goes up exponentially to really large numbers.
If you've ever heard Ray Kurzweil  talk about the future of society,
you've seen these curves--everything goes up exponentially.
Everything is just exponential.
And further, if you go back in time to negative values,
this thing slowly drifts down to 0.
Of course, that's not very exciting, so we never talk about exponential in the negative space.
However, it turns out that all the arguments of the exponential are at best 0
and otherwise are negative, because the exponential is monotonic--
that is the larger its argument, the larger its exponential value.
It ought to be optimized where this thing over here is the largest,
and where is that the case?
Well, it's exactly where µ hits 0.